U.S.
Central Command says
they're investigating
an American drone strike in Syria
that may have resulted in a civilian
being killed.
Central Command
tweeted about the strike afterwards,
but now there are questions
being raised about what was tweeted
and why.
CNN Pentagon correspondent Oren
Liebermann joins us now with details.
So what do we know
about the target of the strike
and what the why sent?
CENTCOM sent out this tweet.
So the strike was carried out on May 3rd
in northwest Syria,
targeting a senior al Qaeda leader.
CENTCOM promised
there would be more information
when details of the operation itself
were sort of confirmed
and became available.
But within hours of the strike happening,
multiple defense officials
tell CNN that General Eric Khairallah,
the head of U.S.
Central Command,
ordered the tweet to be put out,
saying that a senior
al Qaeda leader had been targeted.
That is despite high confidence
when the strike itself
was taken that they knew who
and where they were targeting.
Officials knew
it would still take a few days
to be able to confirm
who was killed in this strike.
And that's at least partially
because there are no U.S.
troops in northwest Syria,
especially after
the devastating earthquake
in that part of the country.
And yet this tweet still went out.
And here we are nearly three weeks later.
And CENTCOM hasn't put out
any more information about
who was the target
or who was killed in this strike.
Now, CNN has spoken
to family members of the casualty
who say he was a 56 year
old farmer who lived in northwest Syria
with ten kids
and had no affiliation with al Qaeda.
Anderson,
So the tweet didn't say
that they had killed an al Qaeda leader.
It just said that they had targeted one
and that there would be more information
and they just never followed up.
And now locals
millions are saying that
a civilian was killed.
Correct.
So now
there is an
assessment
on the part of Central Command,
what's known as a C car,
a civilian casualty
credibility assessment
report, which tries
to figure out
if a civilian was killed,
if it determines that one was killed.
That may, depending on the situation,
the circumstances lead to a more formal
15 six investigation.
And that is a more deeper
look at what went wrong here
and what was the entire process here.
Part of the issue
here, Anderson, is the timeline here.
Strike again was on May 3rd.
Central Command officials
and other officials
tell us that May eight.
So five days later, The Washington Post
gives information to Central Command
that suggests
this may have been a civilian
casualty killed.
And it's still another week
before this assessment is launched.
And we haven't gotten
to a formal investigation yet.
So there's a question here of
why has this taken so long,
especially as some officials
tell us, the fact that it took so long
to try to confirm
who was killed here
in and of itself was a red flag
So, I mean, obviously,
look, this is not the first time
something this has happened.
There was the Kabul strike in 20,
21 that killed ten civilians
during the U.S.
withdrawal from Afghanistan.
Has the Pentagon commented?
You're exactly right, Anderson.
And that is
is very analogous in the closing days
of the withdrawal from Afghanistan.
A U.S.
drone strike killed ten civilians,
including seven children.
The numbers, of course,
are very different here.
We're talking about one person
killed in northwest Syria.
But again, there
we saw the military
initially defending the strike,
saying
it was a strike against an ISIS
key target.
And they stood by that for weeks
until the media,
including CNN,
reported that this wasn't
any affiliation to ISIS.
The target of the strike here.
Yet the Pentagon says
they still have confidence
in the protocols
and processes
set up to protect civilians
in the wake of that strike.
Here is a brigadier
General Pat Ryder from earlier today.
So in terms of CENTCOM's strike,
as you know,
they conducted that strike
on the 3rd of May.
They are investigating
the allegations of civilian casualties.
So, you know,
I think our record speaks for itself
in terms of
how seriously we take these
very few countries
around the world do that.
The secretary has complete confidence
that we will continue to abide
by the policies that we put into place.
So the question now,
how long does this assessment take?
Does it lead to an investigation?
And, Anderson,
at what
point and will
there be calls for accountability
in Libya? And appreciate it. Thank you.